[Music]
hey martin i just got back from a hike
can we go back to anna's problem with
authenticating her api
there's nothing like a hike to clear
your head that's for sure
in a previous episode we followed anna
as she researched and settled on using
json web tokens to secure
take a hike's rest api in this episode
we'll see the coach he wrote
anna is a developer working for take a
hike
a fitness tracking startup she built a
rest api to enable their users
to record hikes from mobile and web apps
she secured the api with json web tokens
in a previous episode we showed the code
for the rest api
it runs on cloud run so it's serverless
and doesn't require any server
maintenance
check out that episode if you want to
see how to write a rest api
here's what anna's prototype looks like
from this webpage
users should be able to sign in using
their identity provider of choice
once they have signed in they should see
their recorded hikes
users should only be able to see their
own hikes
anna reads up on firebase auth which
supports multiple identity providers
it also includes a default user
interface called firebase ui
the code for ana's prototype is linked
in the description below
let's look at the most important pieces
in her javascript code
anna initializes firebase ui which will
display one button
for each identity provider shown to the
user she also tells the firebase ui
library
which page to redirect to after the user
is signed in successfully
finally she renders the firebase ui
component
on the next page the one that users are
redirected to
when they log in successfully anna calls
the get
id token the string she gets back is a
signed
json web token which contains the user's
unique
id after fetching the id token anna's
code requests the user's hikes
by calling the server side rest api her
code includes the id token
in the authorization header of the call
as we saw last time
anna implemented the server-side rest
api in node.js
running on cloud run her server-side
code
reads the json web token from the
authorization header
and extracts the user's id from it
her server-side code then uses this id
to ask the database for that particular
user's hikes
but wait how does anna verify that the
json web token is valid
and how does she extract the user id
from it as mentioned in our previous
video
anna has limited experience with
cryptography that's where the firebase
sdk comes in
if ana imports this package into our
server side code it has a method called
verify id token that does just that
it verifies the token and extracts the
user id from it
if it is valid if the token is
invalid for example if a malicious user
is attacking another rest api
the verify id token call will not
succeed
and anna's code can return an error
that's neat
anna has now secured her rest api so
users can only access their own hikes
and she did it without having to become
an expert in cryptography
the libraries did most of the heavy
lifting that's right chris
it's always important to use tested and
reliable packages when working with
cryptography so
now that take a hike has fixed their
hike recording system i think i'll start
planning my next expedition
where do you think you'll go chris
i'm not sure but i think it'll be
further away than my refrigerator
[Music]